dès maintenant merci j'ai la réflexion
collaborer l'état monsieur pascal
thévenot
merci monsieur le président monsieur
communiste dans un contexte social et
religieux particulièrement tendue les
agents des collectivités font face à une
menace croissante
les agressions se multiplient or dans le
système actuel
l'agresseur n'est pas toujours punis
pire pour peu qu'ils soient insolvable
c'est à la collectivité employeurs de
verser des dommages et intérêts à sa
place voici un exemple éclairant en
décembre dernier dans une petite commune
de la vallée de chevreuse deux agents
techniques ont été violemment agressé
dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions au
motif qu'ils auraient des visages et la
compagne voilée de l'agresseur le
tribunal a rendu son jugement en avril
six mois de prison ferme et 2000 euros
de dommages et intérêts mais le coupable
n'a jamais franchi la porte de la prison
ne sais pas non plus acquitté de sa
dette en raison de sa prétendue
insolvabilité lissiers mandaté par la
commune
nadir pas procéder au recouvrement des
sommes dues par crainte de chatouiller
un agresseur à l'évidence violent et qui
profère des propos peu élégants pour
notre pays pour obtenir réparation
les victimes ont donc saisi le service
dédié le sarvi ce dernier s'est ensuite
tourné vers la collectivité employeurs
qui s'étaient portées partie civile afin
qu'elle indemnise les victimes au titre
de la protection fonctionnelle
vous conviendrez avec moi qu'il est gay
et range qu'une partie civile soit
appelé à régler elle-même les dommages
et intérêts la situation est plus
choquant
lorsque l'agresseur insolvable bénéficie
au quotidien de la solidarité nationale
via le rsa et le logement social
cet exemple est loin d'être isolé
monsieur le premier ministre
que comptez vous faire pour rendre
réellement effectives les sanctions et
empêcher les agresseurs tajan d'échapper
à leurs responsabilités en faisant
porter la faute aux collectivités qui
les emploient merci la parole est à
madame annick jardin ministre de la
fonction publique
si monsieur président monsieur le député
thévenot tout d'abord redire ici que les
violences quotidiennes envers les
l'encontre des fonctionnaires que soit
verbale ou physique sans condamnable et
doit de l'être davantage encore
fortement par nous tous ici
je pense particulièrement à tous ses
fonctionnaires qui sont en direct avec
les usagers sur le terrain aux policiers
aux enseignants au monde hospitalier
nous devons les aider nous devons être à
leur côté mobilisés sans polémique et
sans esprit partisan sur cette question
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'un agent
public est agressé c'est l'état qui est
agressé c'est la république qui est
agressée alors vous dire que ce
gouvernement il est mobilisé sur cette
question il est à la manoeuvre d'abord
vous dire que le ministre de l'intérieur
et les forces de police et de
gendarmerie sont particulièrement
investis sur ces questions que le garde
des sceaux s'est également engagé à
mieux informer sur la réponse pénale
apportée aux violences contre les agents
publics notamment effectivement les
policiers il ya aussi vous l'avez dit le
soutien et la protection que les
employeurs publics doivent apporter à
leurs agents et la loi de déontologie
d'avril dernier à énergie est renforcée
et c'est une première réponse au cas où
vous avez évoqué à renforcer la
protection fonctionnelle des
fonctionnaires notamment prenant en
charge leurs frais de défense pour eux
d'ailleurs et leurs familles il s'agit
bien là de permettre aux agents de se
défendre lorsqu'ils sont agressés et moi
je veux leur dire à tous ces
fonctionnaires qui n'hésite pas qui ne
laisse rien passer et qu'il porte
plainte mais je voudrais aussi dire sans
faire d'amalgamé sur le député que le
climat anti fonctionnaires fait aussi
beaucoup de mal à notre cohésion sociale
trop de candidats à la primaire à droite
et valorisent nos agents publics
estimant qu'ils ne sont qu'un coup qu'il
ne sent aucune charge
parlant de leur suppression en estimant
effectivement que leur utilité